Es steht ziemlich schlecht, um die erde eine forschungsgruppe hat jetzt simuliert was mit unserer zivilisation
Und der erde passieren wird und sie haben sich auch den wahrscheinlichen entwicklungsverlauf von
Außerirdischen zivilisationen vorgenommen und das ergebnis ist ja man muss sagen
Katastrophal demnach läuft alles auf eine große katastrophe nahezu, unausweichlich
Zu und das könnte auch erklären warum wir bisher. Keine außerirdischen
Zivilisationen gefunden haben warum weshalb wieso jetzt sind klicks zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir leben in einem neuen
erdzeitalter dem
anthropozän
Antrieb kommt dabei vom mensch aus dem griechischen
Und geologen sind sich inzwischen sicher dass die entwicklung in
geologischen dimensionen spätestens seit der mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
Menschen gemacht sind wir verändern die erde seitdem massiv, und steuern sie auf eine
Dramatische entwicklung in ein forschungsteam wollte nun wissen wohin sich das ganze entwickelt und wenn man, sich den untergang von der. Einen oder anderen
Zivilisation oder kultur hier auf der erde ansieht dann spricht schon einiges dafür
Fast keine kultur hat irgendwie nachhaltig gewirtschaftet die menschen verhalten
Sich da absolut wie im kindergarten beispiel kapstadt in südafrika
Dabei, gibt es bald kaum noch wasser in chile ist eine ganze bucht auch ganz ausgetrocknet. Weil die menschen. Ihr das wasser
Abgegraben haben, im iran gibt es in einigen. Jahren auch. Kein wasser
Mehr weite teile des landes werden unbewohnbar und die menschen ja die machen einfach nichts
Um es aufzuhalten beim klimawandel im großen stil aber ist das singt oder sind wir nur
Zu blöd das forschungs 7, oben denn frank von der university of rochester
Wollte wissen was anderswo passiert sein könnte. Und uns hier auf der erde noch bevorsteht. Dafür schaut
Sich die forschungsgruppe die klimaentwicklung von verschiedenen planeten an und kombinierten sie mit den erkenntnissen der
population biologie
Und der ablauf scheint immer derselbe zu sein die energieressourcen des heimatplaneten werden demnach immer bis zu den grenzen
ausgeschöpft und führen zu einer ungebremsten vermehrung der spezies
Und der steigende energiebedarf hat folgen für den planeten unter passiert. Und zwar folgendes. Und zwar nahezu
zwangsläufig der heime planet wird aus seinem gleichgewicht gebracht
Um kollabiert 70 prozent der bevölkerung sterben als folge dieser entwicklung in einer
Zweite möglichkeit wird die dramatische entwicklung abgebremst es kommt nicht, zu einem massensterben, und im dritten szenario
Stirbt die ganze spezies aus und aber spielt es überhaupt keine rolle ob die zivilisation auf regenerative energien umsteigt oder nicht die
Bevölkerungsentwicklung an sich die zerstört dem planeten am ende
und sich selbst mit zudem kommt der umstieg
Zu spät der planet hat vorher schon den point of no return erreicht den punkt
Ohne wiederkehr dem forschungsteam ist die begrenztheit der studie bewusst aber sie zeigt deutlich auf vor welcher riesigen
Herausforderungen jede zivilisation steht und wie groß das risiko
der selbstvernichtung
Ist ja inklusive das heimat planet der klimawandel quasi ein test
um
Zu prüfen ob die zivilisation sich wirklich weiterentwickeln kann besteht sie den test nicht
Stirbt sie aus und jetzt habe ich noch etwas ganz besonderes vor witz 1 der wissenschafts videowettbewerb ist wieder angelaufen
Und ihr habt noch bis zum 30 juni zeit eure beiträge einzureichen insgesamt gibt es acht
21.000 euro
Zu gewinnen hammer ja der link zum wettbewerb der ist unten in der video beschreibung einfach draufklicken
und unbedingt mitmachen auf unserem disco server erkenne ich übrigens gerne jedem wasser beachten muss
Um bessere chancen, zu haben da hin kommt. Ihr über den messenger. Dafür hier draufklicken, man. Am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
Klick zum. Social media abonnieren da erfahre das neueste aus der social media welt aber nicht die
Genau, glocke vergessen wenn, er hier drauf klingt. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken aliens können wir sie leichter finden bis. Dann
bleib dran